This is an amazing documentary called Please Vote for Me about an election in a third grade class by a filmmaker named Weijun Chen. It takes place in a city called Wuhan in central China. The eight year olds are told that they are going to vote to decide who is going to be the class monitor. It's the first election in their school ever. None of them has ever witnessed or taken part in anything like this at all.
这是一部名为《请为我投票》的精彩纪录片，讲述了由电影制作人陈为军拍摄的一场三年级班级选举。故事发生在中国的中心城市武汉。这些八岁的孩子被告知，他们将投票决定谁能成为班长。这是他们学校有史以来第一次选举。他们中没有一个人见过或参与过这样的事情。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
"Isn't this new?" their teacher asks them. And one of the three candidates, a little butterball of a kid named Cheng Cheng, turns out to be a natural politician. With no adults prompting him, he immediately starts button-holing his classmates and making promises.
“这不是很新鲜吗？”他们的老师问他们。其中一位候选人，一个叫成成的小胖子，表现出了天生的政治家潜质。在没有成年人指点的情况下，他立刻开始拉拢同学并做出承诺。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
"Vote for me," he tells a little boy, "I'll make you steady committee officer." Quickly the parents get involved, coaching the kids, helping write their speeches. One dad who's with the police department basically wins the election for his son by arranging for a class trip on the city's monorail, which the kids love, and by giving his son little presents to hand out to every kid in the class moments before they vote.
“投我一票，”他对一个小男孩说，“我会让你当纪律委员。”很快，家长们也参与进来，指导孩子，帮他们写演讲稿。其中一位在公安部门工作的父亲，通过安排全班去坐城市轻轨（孩子们很喜欢）以及在投票前给全班每个孩子发放小礼物，基本上为他儿子赢得了这场选举。
But the kids own instincts are really interesting to watch too. There's this scene where one of the candidates-- a girl named Xiaofei is about to do a flute recital as part of the competition. Her two friends are going to dance a ballet with red scarves around her as she plays. Before she starts, though, Cheng Cheng tells a friend, "After Xiaofei performs, you must shout, that's terrible, got it?"
但孩子们自己的本能也同样令人关注。片中有一个场景，其中一名候选人——一个叫晓菲的女孩，正准备进行长笛独奏作为比赛的一部分。在她演奏时，她的两个朋友要围着她跳芭蕾舞。然而，在开始之前，成成告诉一个朋友：“晓菲表演完后，你一定要大喊，那太糟糕了，听到了吗？”
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
Which results in a whole group of kids, including Cheng Cheng and Luo Lei-- Luo Lei's the other candidate in this race-- taunting her, "Xiaofei, Xiaofei, slowest eater. Xiaofei, Xiaofei, rotten gossip."
结果导致一大群孩子，包括成成和罗雷（罗雷是这场竞选中的另一位候选人），一起嘲讽她：“晓菲晓菲，吃饭最慢。晓菲晓菲，是个长舌妇。”
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
Xiaofei looks around confused-- nothing like this has ever happened. And she's little, right, her feelings are right on her face. She blinks, she looks over to her teacher for help, she looks down and winces and starts crying. Another little girl in pink, at her desk, she starts crying too, witnessing this. The teacher calls a break, ushers Xiaofei from the room.
晓菲困惑地环顾四周——这种事以前从未发生过。她还很小，对吧，她的情绪都写在脸上了。她眨了眨眼，看向老师寻求帮助，随后低下头，痛苦地抽泣起来。坐在课桌旁的另一个穿粉色衣服的小女孩目睹了这一切，也开始哭泣。老师叫了暂停，把晓菲领出了教室。
Cheng Cheng then goes to Xiaofei in the hallway and say, "I apologize to you for Luo Lei." As if Luo Lei was the one who organized the chanting, not him. Then he gets Luo Lei to apologize. And then, not only is Xiaofei crying, both the little boys, they both burst into tears also. Remember, they're all just eight years old.
随后成成走到走廊里对晓菲说：“我替罗雷向你道歉。”仿佛组织起哄的人是罗雷，而不是他。接着，他让罗雷去道歉。然后，不仅晓菲在哭，两个小男孩也都放声大哭起来。别忘了，他们都才八岁。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
The camera moves down the aisle of the classroom, and we see lots of other kids are crying as well. It's like they accidentally invented negative campaigning, on their own, in their own classroom, tried it out, and then realized just how mean and wrong it is. Something adults seem to forget sometimes.
镜头穿过教室的过道，我们看到许多其他孩子也在哭。这就像他们自己发明了负面竞选，在自己的教室里尝试了一番，然后意识到这有多么刻薄和错误。这是成年人有时似乎会忘记的事情。
Today on our show, we have stories of children thrust into the world of politics-- a world that was really built for adults with thicker skins. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show in three acts, these children take up presidential politics, global warming, and in our last act, they're put in charge of their own school-- make all the rules, including discipline. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目，讲述了孩子们被推入政治世界的故事——一个原本为脸皮更厚的成年人建立的世界。这里是WBEZ芝加哥，由国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们的节目分三幕，这些孩子将讨论总统政治、全球变暖，而在最后一幕中，他们被赋予管理自己学校的权力——制定所有规则，包括纪律。请继续收听。
Act One, Trickle Down History. Now we move to a group of teachers in California, teachers who are sending their students out to understand a very American kind of politics-- presidential politics. Starlee Kine tells the story.
第一幕，涓滴历史。现在我们转向加州的一群教师，他们正让学生们去了解一种非常典型的美国式政治——总统政治。斯塔利·基恩讲述了这个故事。
When I was in high school, my class took a trip to the Richard Nixon Library. I remember putting on a pair of large headphones that whispered snippets of the Watergate recordings into my ears. I remember being shown into this little carpeted room. Our teacher tells we're in luck, there's a very special guest there for us that day. We hope it's someone good. A man with a flattop haircut enters. His name is H.R. Haldeman. He has something important to tell us. We hope he wants to tell us that he is not the real special guest. We have no idea who he is.
当我上高中的时候，我们班去理查德·尼克松图书馆参观过。我记得当时戴上一副大耳机，里面传出水门事件录音的片段。我记得被带进一个铺着地毯的小房间。老师告诉我们运气很好，那天有一位非常特别的嘉宾。我们希望是位重量级人物。一个留着平头的人走了进来。他的名字叫H.R.霍尔德曼。他有些重要的事情要告诉我们。我们当时多么希望他告诉我们他并不是那位特别嘉宾。我们根本不知道他是谁。
If your history's a little foggy, H.R. Haldeman was President Nixon's Chief of Staff. He was a pal and a confidante. When recordings of Nixon in the White House were released, there were hours and hours of recorded conversation between the two of them on the phone, like a couple of mean girls plotting how to take over the rest of the school. After Watergate broke, it became clear that Haldeman was involved, and he turned in his resignation. It was a big enough deal that Nixon went on TV to announce it.
如果你的历史知识有点模糊的话，H.R.霍尔德曼曾是尼克松总统的办公厅主任。他是尼克松的朋友和心腹。当白宫的录音被公布时，里面有长达数小时的两人电话交谈录音，就像两个心机女孩在密谋如何接管学校。水门事件爆发后，霍尔德曼卷入其中的事实变得明朗，他递交了辞呈。这件事闹得很大，以至于尼克松亲自上电视宣布了这一消息。
Today in one of the most difficult decisions of my presidency, I accepted the resignations of two of my closest associates in the White House-- Bob Haldeman, John Erlichman.
今天，在我的总统任期内最困难的决定之一，我接受了我在白宫最亲密的两位同僚的辞呈——鲍勃·霍尔德曼和约翰·埃利希曼。
Nixon threw his good friend H.R. Haldeman under the bus. Haldeman was convicted of conspiracy, obstruction of justice, and perjury. He served 18 months in prison, passing the time by working as a chemist in the prison's sewage treatment plant. Once he was released, he got involved in various business ventures. He became the owner of eight Sizzler steak houses. He receded into normal life, apparently only to resurface for the occasional public appearance in front of a room full of high school students.
尼克松为了自保抛弃了他的好友霍尔德曼。霍尔德曼因串谋、妨碍司法和伪证罪被判刑。他在监狱里服刑18个月，期间在监狱的污水处理厂当化学工来打发时间。出狱后，他参与了各种商业投机，成为了八家西斯勒牛排馆的老板。他回归了正常生活，显然只是偶尔为了在满屋子高中生面前露个脸才重回公众视野。
That day in the library, we didn't know about any of Haldeman's history. I, for one, would have appreciated being told about the Sizzler steak house part up front. I remember clearly that Haldeman seemed like this sad, broken man. He wasn't wearing a suit, he didn't seem like someone with any authority, someone who was a part of history. It seemed clear that Haldeman was there that day to get us to stand in his shoes and see Watergate from his perspective. It was a very freaky Friday kind of moment-- see how hard it is to be an adult for a day.
在图书馆的那天，我们对霍尔德曼的历史一无所知。我个人认为，如果一开始就告诉我们关于西斯勒牛排馆的事会更好。我清楚地记得，霍尔德曼看起来像个悲伤、破碎的人。他没有穿西装，看起来不像个有权威、参与过历史的人。显然，霍尔德曼那天在那里，是为了让我们站在他的角度看待水门事件。那是一个非常诡异的时刻——让我们体验一天当大人的感觉。
And if you'll allow me this tangent, I was reminded of all this recently when I heard about something similar happening now in Simi Valley, California. That's where the library is for California's other Republican president, Ronald Reagan.
请允许我跑个题，我最近听到加州西米谷正在发生类似的事情，这让我想起了这些。那里有加州另一位共和党总统罗纳德·里根的图书馆。
On a sunny Friday morning, I watch a class of fifth graders climb down off their school bus in their especially nice field trip clothes. They're here because the library does these reenactments where the students actually get to play Ronald Reagan and his various staff members-- stand in Reagan's shoes for the day. The kids file inside where a cheerful woman who works for the library stands in front of a large map with countries either red or blue.
在一个阳光明媚的周五上午，我看着一个五年级班级的学生穿着特意挑选的郊游服装从校车上下来。他们来这里是因为图书馆举办了这种重演活动，学生们真的可以扮演罗纳德·里根和他的各种幕僚——体验一天里根的角色。孩子们鱼贯进入，一位在图书馆工作的开朗女士站在一张标着红色或蓝色国家的地图前。
Who wants to tell me about the map? What do you know about the map? Yes?
谁想告诉我关于这张地图的事？你们对这张地图了解什么？是的？
All of the red countries are the Communist countries.
所有的红色国家都是共产主义国家。
Excellent. Very good. Is this a map of what it looks like today? No? When is this map? What're we looking at? What time period? Yes, sir?
非常好。非常棒。这是当今世界的地图吗？不是？这是什么时候的地图？我们在看什么？什么时间段？是的，先生？
The 1980s.
20世纪80年代。
Very good. Actually 1983. And in 1983 who was president?
非常好。其实是1983年。1983年谁是总统？
Ronald Reagan.
罗纳德·里根。
It's obvious the kids have been studying Ronald Reagan all week, and in particular, the invasion of Grenada. One of the great things about tagging around on an elementary school field trip is you re-learn all the history lessons that you'd not only forgotten, but question whether you ever learned in the first place. Do you remember anything at all about the invasion of Grenada? Don't worry, they'll explain to us.
显然孩子们整个星期都在学习罗纳德·里根，特别是关于入侵格林纳达的事件。跟着小学生郊游的一大好处是，你能重温那些你不仅遗忘，甚至怀疑自己是否学过的历史课。你还记得关于入侵格林纳达的任何事情吗？别担心，他们会为我们解释。
In 1983, Grenada is what color? Everyone tell me?
1983年，格林纳达是什么颜色的？大家告诉我？
Red.
红色。
Very good, it's red. That means it's a Communist country.
非常好，是红色的。那意味着它是一个共产主义国家。
The kids go on to talk about the rebels who overthrew the Grenadian government in 1983 and about the group of 800 hundred or so American medical students who were stranded there and who became instant pawns in US Cold War politics.
孩子们继续谈论1983年推翻格林纳达政府的叛军，以及那里大约800名被困的美国医学生，他们瞬间成了美国冷战政治的棋子。
But why do we really care about what's going on in Grenada? There's a specific reason why we're so concerned-- specifically, why President Reagan was concerned. Yes, sir?
但我们为什么要真正关心格林纳达正在发生的事情？我们如此关注有一个具体的原因——特别是因为里根总统很关心。是的，先生？
Because they might have joined armies and taken over the US.
因为他们可能联合军队并接管美国。
OK, so we have Cuba, we have Grenada, and there's also Nicaragua at the time that are all Communist, and they're kind of close to the United States. So it could be that it causes a problem for the United States if they were to come to us and wanted to maybe make us Communist, right?
好的，所以当时我们有古巴、格林纳达，还有尼加拉瓜，它们都是共产主义国家，而且离美国很近。所以如果他们向我们走来，想要让我们也变成共产主义，可能会对美国造成问题，对吧？
That's right. We were afraid Cuba, Grenada, and Nicaragua, with their collective population of 13 million would come over, defeat the largest military in the world, and turn us all Communist. And then, just in case there's any doubt in the kids minds about how terrible this would be, a staff member gives them a quick primer on the evils of Communism.
没错。我们害怕古巴、格林纳达和尼加拉瓜这总共1300万人口会打过来，击败世界上最强大的军队，让我们全都变成共产主义者。然后，为了防止孩子们对这有多糟糕产生任何怀疑，一位工作人员给他们快速普及了共产主义的邪恶。
Very good. In a Communist country, you have limited rights and freedoms. If you wanted to go and get a job and earn a living, could you keep your money? Could you? Who has all the money in a Communist country? What do you think?
非常好。在一个共产主义国家，你的权利和自由是有限的。如果你想去找份工作赚钱，你能保有你的钱吗？你能吗？在共产主义国家，谁拥有所有的钱？你们觉得呢？
The government.
政府。
The government, very good. Now if you wanted to buy some land, or you wanted to buy a home, you wanted to buy property, could you do that in a Communist country? Who owns all the property? Everyone?
政府，非常好。那么如果你想买块地，或者你想买个家，你想购买财产，你能在共产主义国家那样做吗？谁拥有所有财产？大家？
The government.
政府。
Very good.
非常好。
The reason for all this studying up is that the kids are going to reenact the invasion. The class is divided up, with one third playing members of the Oval Office, one third playing the press, and one third playing the military. And one kid will play Ronald Reagan himself. The staff begin to hand out badges designating which kid is what.
进行所有这些学习的原因是，孩子们即将重演这场入侵。班级被分成三部分，三分之一扮演白宫椭圆形办公室成员，三分之一扮演媒体，三分之一扮演军方。还有一个孩子将亲自扮演罗纳德·里根。工作人员开始分发徽章，指定每个孩子担任什么角色。
Secretary of State, Nicolette Schultz.
国务卿，尼科莱特·舒尔茨。
The military commanders are next, followed by the press. The naming of one little girl as White House Bureau Chief prompts a classmate to mutter, "I knew it," under his breath. I ask him why, and he tells me that one time when they were in kindergarten, she played a news anchor, so-- his voice trails off. Without fail, the kids ooh and aah over every position that is called out.
接下来是军事指挥官，然后是媒体。一名小女孩被任命为白宫分局局长，引得一名同学小声嘟囔了一句：“我早就知道。”我问他为什么，他告诉我，他们幼儿园时，她演过新闻主播，所以——他的声音渐渐弱了下去。毫无例外，每叫到一个职位，孩子们都会发出惊叹声。
The kids are ushered to a room with three closed doors. The library's really fancy. Flat screen TVs flash on, and actors playing nondescript officials explain the kids' mission, and the potential consequences of their actions.
孩子们被带到一个有三扇关闭门的房间。图书馆真的很豪华。平板电视闪烁起来，扮演普通官员的演员向孩子们解释了他们的任务以及行动的潜在后果。
When you walk through these doors, you will no longer be students.
当你们走进这些门时，你们将不再是学生。
You will make history. Lives are at stake.
你们将创造历史。生命危在旦夕。
Adult staff members are not here to answer questions or help you. The responsibility is entirely yours.
成年工作人员不在这里回答问题或提供帮助。责任完全由你们承担。
President Reagan, please report to the Oval Office and find your desk.
里根总统，请向椭圆形办公室报告并找到你的办公桌。
The three doors swing open in unison revealing three different sets-- the Oval Office, the press room, and the command center of a battleship. Everyone goes to their assigned room. The battleship is amazing-- it's dimly lit with lots of flashing lights and a gadget with toggle switches in front of every chair. And if there's anything a kid loves, it's toggle switches.
三扇门同时打开，露出了三个不同的场景——椭圆形办公室、新闻发布室和战舰指挥中心。每个人都去了分配好的房间。战舰非常惊人——灯光昏暗，闪烁着许多灯光，每把椅子前面都有一个带拨动开关的小装置。如果说孩子们喜欢什么，那就是拨动开关。
Welcome to the Command Decision Center.
欢迎来到指挥决策中心。
Whoa.
哇。
Oh my God.
噢，天哪。
Oh my Jesus.
我的上帝啊。
The press corps is led through another door. A staff member flat out lies to them by telling them that the press room is every bit as exciting as a battleship. It looks like a hotel conference room. The best selling point the staff can muster is that the room is large.
媒体团被带到了另一扇门后。一名工作人员直截了当地骗他们说，新闻发布室和战舰一样令人兴奋。它看起来就像个酒店会议室。工作人员能给出的最大卖点就是这个房间很大。
In fact, the press room is bigger than the press room in the White House, so that's pretty exciting.
事实上，这个新闻发布室比白宫的那个还要大，所以这很令人兴奋。
The President and his cabinet head into a replica of the Reagan era Oval Office, complete with a jar of jelly beans on the desk, which the kids are instructed to not even think about eating.
总统和他的内阁进入了一个里根时代的椭圆形办公室复制品，办公桌上甚至放着一罐果冻豆，孩子们被指示连想都不要想去吃。
Secretary Weinberger.
温伯格部长。
Today's President Reagan is a blond fifth grader with an athletic build. My guess is he's a popular kid, but a benevolent one. He seems to take being named leader of the free world in stride, as though it's the sort of thing that happens to him often. Here's how it all works. The invasion is broken down into a series of A or B options. For instance, A, have diplomatic talks with Grenada, or B, evacuate the medical students. A, evacuate the medical students, or B, overthrow the Communist government. Each kid gets a vote, but President Reagan has final say.
今天的里根总统是一个身材健壮的金发五年级学生。我猜他是个受欢迎的孩子，但也很友善。他似乎很自然地接受了被任命为自由世界领袖这件事，仿佛这是他常遇到的事。这一切是这样运作的：入侵被分解为一系列A或B选项。例如，A，与格林纳达进行外交谈判；或B，撤离医学生。A，撤离医学生；或B，推翻共产主义政府。每个孩子都有一票投票权，但里根总统有最终决定权。
Well, both of the options are-- well, I considered both of the options, but I think a smaller, faster force-- let's say the smaller, faster force is over powered, we have very small chances. And if we have a big army coming there, then we have better chances and it will take quicker, so I go with A.
好吧，这两个选项——嗯，我考虑过这两个选项，但我认为如果是一个更小、更快的部队——假设这个更小、更快的部队被压制了，我们的机会就非常小。如果我们有一支大军队去那里，那么我们有更好的机会，而且动作会更快，所以我选A。
The President inputs his answer into a dramatic red phone located right next to the jelly bean jar on his desk. Before they start, the kids were told that there aren't right or wrong answers, but the whole thing's rigged to make what Ronald Reagan did in 1983 look like the most appealing option. Each time the kids choose to do what he did, a bell goes off as though they've won a tropical vacation in Grenada, instead of an invasion.
总统将他的答案输入到办公桌上那罐果冻豆旁边的一部引人注目的红色电话中。在开始之前，孩子们被告知没有正确或错误的答案，但整个活动是经过设计的，旨在使罗纳德·里根在1983年的所作所为看起来是最具吸引力的选择。每次孩子们选择做他当时做的事情时，铃声就会响起，就好像他们赢得了一次格林纳达热带度假，而不是一场入侵。
Nicely done, that is another correct response according to President Reagan.
干得漂亮，根据里根总统的记录，这是另一个正确的反应。
Excellent work, President Reagan. Ordering a large invasion ensured that we would get the job done.
工作做得非常出色，里根总统。下令大规模入侵确保了我们能完成任务。
Again and again, President Reagan makes the same decisions as, well, President Reagan. Everything is going great until there's a news flash. Apparently the kids in the press room have been hard at work. An actress playing a reporter appears on the screen.
一次又一次，里根总统做出了和——嗯，里根总统一样的决定。一切进展顺利，直到出现了一条新闻快讯。显然新闻发布室里的孩子们一直在努力工作。一名扮演记者的女演员出现在屏幕上。
All right, I'm not sure what this is, let's take a look.
好的，我不确定这是什么，让我们看看。
Confidential sources tell this reporter that two US aircraft carriers headed to Lebanon have been rerouted to Grenada.
秘密消息源告诉本记者，两艘前往黎巴嫩的美国航母已被改道前往格林纳达。
Wait a minute, how did they get this information? President Reagan, have you talked to the press?
等等，他们是怎么得到这个信息的？里根总统，你和媒体谈过话吗？
Not yet.
还没有。
Any of you talk to the press?
你们中有谁和媒体谈过话吗？
No.
没有。
This is top secret information. I'm not sure how the press got this story, but this is going to cause some problems for us.
这是绝密信息。我不确定媒体是怎么得到这个消息的，但这会给我们造成一些问题。
Here's how it went down. In real life 1983, the press was somehow tipped off about the story in Grenada. President Reagan and the military had been planning a surprise attack. And so when the news got out, they had to decide whether to go ahead with the invasion, even though Grenada would be waiting for them, or to abort. President Reagan, again, like his predecessor President Reagan, decides to stick with the plan. The red phone dings. The US goes to war for three days.
事情是这样的。在现实中的1983年，媒体不知何故提前获悉了格林纳达的消息。里根总统和军方一直在策划突袭。所以当消息泄露后，他们必须决定是否要继续入侵，尽管格林纳达可能已经在那等着他们了，或者放弃。里根总统，再次像他前任里根总统一样，决定坚持原计划。红色电话响起。美国进行了为期三天的战争。
After it's over, the staff does a little debrief with everyone. They talk with the kids about what happened, pointing out how it was especially bad when they lost the element of surprise.
结束后，工作人员和大家进行了一次简短的总结。他们和孩子们谈论了发生的事情，指出当失去突袭的突然性时，情况有多么糟糕。
And how did we lose the element of surprise? What happened? Yes, sir?
我们是如何失去突然性的？发生了什么？是的，先生？
Reporters somehow figured out the information, which was top secret, and ruined the surprise.
记者不知何故查到了这些绝密信息，并破坏了突袭。
All right, so President Reagan, now that we know it was the reporters-- we saw the report-- what are you going to do to them for releasing this information?
好的，所以里根总统，既然我们知道是记者干的——我们看到了报道——你打算因为他们泄露这些信息而对他们做什么？
The staff ask the kids if the press had a right to tell the public. They go over the nuts and bolts of what freedom of the press means, and decide that what the reporters did was legal.
工作人员问孩子们新闻媒体是否有权告诉公众。他们复习了新闻自由意味着什么的具体内容，并认定记者们的所作所为是合法的。
They can't have any consequences for what they did. However, just because they have the freedoms, do all of you think that they should have used that freedom today?
他们所做的事情不能承担任何后果。然而，仅仅因为他们拥有自由，你们所有人认为他们今天应该使用那种自由吗？
No.
不。
Now we did lose some military lives. I'm here to inform you that we lost 19 soldiers in the fighting. Now we can't directly say that's because of the press, but did it help that they released the story?
我们确实损失了一些军队人员。我在这里通知你们，我们在战斗中损失了19名士兵。现在我们不能直接说这是因为媒体的原因，但他们发布报道有帮助吗？
No.
没有。
No, it certainly didn't help.
没有，当然没有帮助。
No one pointed out the those 19 soldiers might have lived if the Oval Office had done things differently, or that invading countries is a dangerous business and casualties tend to come with the territory. Instead, one by one, you can see it on the kids' faces-- how it could have been perfect if only it wasn't for the press. And then the staff tells the kids they're going to rejoin their classmates, the ones that were in the other room playing reporters.
没有人指出如果椭圆形办公室采取不同的处理方式，那19名士兵也许能活下来，或者入侵其他国家是一项危险的生意，伤亡往往是难免的。相反，你可以一个接一个地在孩子们的脸上看到——如果不是因为媒体，一切本可以多么完美。然后工作人员告诉孩子们，他们要回到其他同学身边去了，就是那些在另一个房间扮演记者的孩子们。
Now it is time for me take you into the press room for a press conference. That means you're going to see the press. I ask you to be polite, but point out to them that maybe their actions had some consequences today.
现在是我带你们去新闻发布室参加新闻发布会的时候了。这意味着你们将见到媒体。我请你们礼貌一些，但要向他们指出，也许他们的行为今天产生了一些后果。
Come on in. Did you guys hear our story? Did you like our story?
进来吧。你们听到了我们的报道吗？你们喜欢我们的报道吗？
No.
不。
So you guys saw our story, but you don't like it?
所以你们看到了我们的报道，但你们不喜欢？
No. You destroyed our plan.
不。你们破坏了我们的计划。
We destroyed your plan?
我们破坏了你们的计划？
Yes!
是的！
Everyone is trying to get in as much glaring and as much head shaking as possible. The phrase element of surprise and 19 dead comes up again, and again, and again. The kids seem genuinely upset.
每个人都在努力瞪大眼睛，不停地摇头。突然性以及19人死亡这些词被反复提起。孩子们看起来非常难过。
I don't understand, what plan did we destroy? One representative. Yes?
我不明白，我们破坏了什么计划？一位代表。是的？
Well, the reason why we really didn't want it to go out was because if they didn't know, we would still have the 19, and we would still have-- it just, it ruined our plan our action.
嗯，我们真的不希望它发布的原因是，如果他们不知道，我们就不会损失19人，我们还会——它只是，它毁了我们的计划我们的行动。
It's a strange experience watching little kids struggling to become adults before their time. They were too young to understand exactly what had just happened, but old enough to feel guilt about the blood on their hands. It surely must have been the first time in their lives that they'd been accused of causing a person's death, and yet they took to it so naturally.
看着小孩子们在他们那个年纪之前挣扎着成为成年人，这是一种奇怪的经历。他们太年轻了，无法理解刚刚发生了什么，但已经足够成熟到为自己手中的血感到内疚。这肯定必须是他们一生中第一次被指控导致他人死亡，然而他们却表现得如此自然。
I know Reagan isn't Nixon and Grenada isn't Watergate. And that difference is particularly stark when you've been to both their respective libraries like I have. In Reagan's, he's celebrated as a winner. In Nixon's, the tone is apologetic. But both libraries are saying the same thing-- see it my way.
我知道里根不是尼克松，格林纳达也不是水门事件。当你去过他们各自的图书馆时，那种区别尤其鲜明。在里根的图书馆里，他被誉为胜利者。在尼克松的图书馆里，语气充满了歉意。但两个图书馆都在说同样的话——用我的方式看世界。
I recently called up the Nixon Library to ask them about the day my class met H.R. Haldeman. They dug up an old program and they also sent me a list of questions the adults gave us to ask him. They might as well have been lifted straight off the transcript of the Watergate hearings. Why didn't you burn the White House tapes? How do you think the 18 and a half minute gap occurred? Why did your critics want you out? Are you sorry?
我最近打电话给尼克松图书馆，问他们关于我班级见到H.R.霍尔德曼那天的事。他们翻出了一个旧节目单，还发给我一份成年人让我们问他的问题清单。这些问题简直就是直接从水门事件听证会的文字记录中摘录出来的。为什么你不销毁白宫录音带？你认为那18分半的空白是怎么产生的？为什么你的批评者想让你下台？你感到抱歉吗？
From the second Haldeman opened his mouth, we could tell he was angry, and that this wasn't like any field trip we'd ever been on before. He hadn't prepared a speech or anything like that. He would start barking his answers at us before we had even finished getting the questions out. An LA Times article about the visit quotes him as saying, "For Pete's sake, don't believe what you read in history books just because of the fact that those words are printed."
从霍尔德曼开口的第二秒起，我们就知道他在生气，而且这和我们之前参加的任何郊游都不一样。他没有准备演讲稿之类的东西。还没等我们问完问题，他就会对我们吼出答案。《洛杉矶时报》关于那次访问的一篇文章引用他的话说：“看在上帝的份上，别仅仅因为书上印着那些话就相信你在历史书中读到的内容。”
He told us he was improperly convicted and never had a chance during his trial because of the so-called judge. He kept reminding us of all the good Nixon had done, that we shouldn't be mad at Nixon for Haldeman's downfall-- it wasn't his fault. Even the proximity of where he was standing felt off. He was too vulnerable and close, as though he was practically sitting down on the floor with us. Despite his gruffness, I do actually remember feeling really sorry for him.
他告诉我们他被不正当地定罪了，而且因为所谓的法官，他在审判中没有机会。他不断提醒我们尼克松所做的所有好事，我们不应该因为霍尔德曼的垮台而生尼克松的气——那不是他的错。甚至他站的地方距离感都很奇怪。他显得太脆弱、靠得太近，仿佛实际上正坐在地板上和我们在一起。尽管他很粗鲁，但我确实记得为他感到非常难过。
He seemed to care more about what we thought about him than what our teachers or any other adults did. They had already formed their opinions. He meant nothing to us, and that meant something to him. It meant someday, when we told our kids about Bob Haldeman, history wouldn't have to win just because those words are printed. And it worked. I liked him. I didn't think he was innocent, but I felt bad he wasn't.
他似乎更在意我们怎么看他，而不是我们的老师或任何其他成年人怎么看。他们已经形成了自己的观点。他对我们来说毫无意义，而这对他是件大事。这意味着有一天，当我们告诉孩子们关于鲍勃·霍尔德曼的事时，历史不必仅仅因为那些文字被打印出来就必须获胜。而这奏效了。我喜欢他。我不认为他是无辜的，但我为他不是无辜的感到难过。
Different school groups cycled through the Reagan Library throughout the day. I have to wait until the last one before I get to see what happens when a kid tries to alter the script.
不同的小组全天轮流参观里根图书馆。我必须等到最后一组，才能看看当一个孩子试图修改剧本时会发生什么。
Secretary Baker?
贝克国务卿？
That kid is William Miller, a skinny boy with glasses who's playing Ronald Reagan this time. The way his suit jacket hangs on him reminds me of the kind of movie where the kid is turned into an adult, and then back into a kid. William is quite and thoughtful. Each time he is called upon to make his decision, he adds his own special touch. He insists on consulting with the little girl playing Vice President Bush. It's hard not to see it as half sound political strategy on the President's part and half crush.
那个孩子是威廉·米勒，一个戴着眼镜、瘦瘦的男孩，这次他扮演罗纳德·里根。他那件西装外套穿在他身上的样子让我想起了那种孩子变成大人、然后再变回孩子的电影。威廉文静且善于思考。每当他被要求做决定时，他都会加上自己的独特触感。他坚持要咨询扮演副总统布什的小女孩。很难不把这看作是总统的一半明智的政治策略，另一半则是青涩的好感。
And Vice President, may I please ask you a quick question? Why do you personally think that it should be B?
副总统，我可以请教你一个简短的问题吗？你个人认为为什么应该是B？
It's just safer and less risky than A.
这比A更安全，风险更小。
OK.
好的。
This group tackles the same questions as the first group-- whether to discuss or evacuate, and then whether to evacuate or invade. As the theatrics start to pick up, William looks worried. He quietly reads the library's instructions to himself.
这一组处理的是和第一组相同的问题——是讨论还是撤离，然后是撤离还是入侵。随着戏剧性开始升温，威廉看起来很担心。他安静地阅读图书馆给自己的说明。
The decision is not to be taken lightly. Using military force for any reason is risky and may cost innocent lives.
决策不应轻率做出。因任何原因使用武力都是冒险的，可能会以无辜生命为代价。
There's a beeping sound like a time bomb is about to go off. President Reagan again consults his VP, shooting a look at the clock.
有一种像定时炸弹即将引爆的滴答声。里根总统再次咨询了他的副总统，瞥了一眼时钟。
Well, I think I'm going to go with vote A, and the reason for that is if we do go to war with Grenada, there's also the threat that other Communist countries like the Soviet Union could also come in and help to try to defeat us, and I don't think that that's necessary, to have that.
嗯，我想我还是会选A，原因是如果我们真的和格林纳达开战，还有一种威胁是苏联等其他共产主义国家也可能加入并试图打败我们，我不认为有必要那样做。
That sensible argument he just made about the Soviet Union wasn't fed to him by an adult-- he came up with it on his own. And it's at this point that William goes off script. He goes against the real Reagan. He decides not to invade, to just get the Americans out. Feeling good about his choice, President Reagan picks up the red phone and punches in A. The sound that comes out of the phone is one that anyone who ever watched a game show on TV will immediately recognize as the sound of being wrong.
他刚刚提出的关于苏联的那个明智论点并不是由成年人喂给他的——是他自己想出来的。而就在这一点上，威廉偏离了剧本。他违背了真实的里根。他决定不入侵，只是把美国人撤出来。对自己的选择感到满意，里根总统拿起红色电话输入了A。电话里传出的声音，任何看过电视游戏节目的人都会立刻认出那是代表“错误”的声音。
Oh, why did we hear that sound?
噢，为什么我们听到了那个声音？
The US government will only overthrow the government of another nation if it believes that nation poses a direct, specific threat to American safety. In 1983, President Reagan decided that Grenada presented such a threat, and ordered a full scale military operation to replace Grenada's hostile Communist government with a friendly democracy, a government similar to our own.
只有当美国政府认为另一个国家对美国安全构成直接、具体的威胁时，才会推翻该国政府。1983年，里根总统认定格林纳达构成了这种威胁，并下令进行大规模军事行动，用友好的民主政体取代格林纳达敌对的共产主义政府，即建立一个类似于我们自己的政府。
President Reagan soldiers on, despite now knowing that he'll be overtaken by the tide of history, no matter what he does. Soon the same fake reporter comes on again, saying that the press has leaked the story. The kids rush to the President's desk.
里根总统坚持了下来，尽管现在知道无论他做什么，都将被历史的潮流淹没。很快，同样的冒牌记者又出现了，说媒体泄露了消息。孩子们冲向总统办公桌。
Abort the mission. Abort the mission. Abort the mission. Abort, abort, abort, abort. Everyone says abort.
中止任务。中止任务。中止任务。中止、中止、中止、中止。每个人都说中止。
William agrees. They should abort the mission. He figures they can go back to the original plan of just evacuating the students, and then invade later when they've gotten the element of surprise back. He warily inputs his answer into the red phone.
威廉同意了。他们应该中止任务。他认为他们可以回到最初的撤离学生的计划，然后等恢复了突袭的突然性后再入侵。他小心翼翼地将答案输入红色电话。
OK, let's see what President Reagan did in 1983. Let's see, it sounds like they continued on the mission.
好的，让我们看看里根总统1983年是怎么做的。让我们看看，听起来他们继续执行了任务。
Sometimes in the heat of the moment, even the best leader can lose sight of what's most important. In this case, the safety of the American students, and the freedom of the Grenadian people.
有时在紧要关头，即使是最好的领导人也会忘记什么才是最重要的。在这种情况下，是美国学生的安全和格林纳达人民的自由。
President Reagan looks stricken. His coat seems bigger than ever. Again the class files out. Again it's the press kids versus everyone else. Again there's the chaos and blame. All through the library's lobby are clusters of ten year olds fighting to the death.
里根总统看起来深受打击。他的外套看起来比以往任何时候都大。班级再次鱼贯而出。又变成了媒体组对阵其他所有人。又是混乱和指责。整个图书馆大厅里都是争吵到死的一群十岁孩子。
We had freedom of speech, right? Right?
我们有言论自由，对吧？对吧？
You killed people. You killed 19 soldiers. How would you like to be killed?
你们杀人了。你们杀了19名士兵。你们愿意被杀吗？
President Reagan is slowly getting swallowed up by the crowd. Adults can sometimes put on this big show, letting you make the decisions, letting you be in charge, when what they really want is to convince you that their way is best, that they're not bad people, that the decisions they made were the right ones, and that if you were in their position, you'd have done it the same way. They'd really like you to believe that, maybe so they can believe it too.
里根总统正慢慢被人群吞没。成年人有时会演这种大戏，让你做决定，让你当家作主，而他们真正想要的是让你相信他们的方式是最好的，他们不是坏人，他们做出的决定是正确的，如果你处在他们的位置，你也会这样做。他们真的希望你相信这一点，也许这样他们自己也能相信。
Starlee Kine, lives in Los Angeles. Coming up, children vote to decide all the rules in their school, including can they play video games while at school? What they decide in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
斯塔利·基恩，住在洛杉矶。接下来，孩子们投票决定他们学校的所有规则，包括他们在校期间可以玩电子游戏吗？他们决定了什么，一分钟后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, kid politics. Stories or what happens when adults-- usually educators-- put kids in the hot seat and tell them to grapple with adult political decisions. We've arrived at act two of our show.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，儿童政治。故事是关于当成年人——通常是教育者——把孩子们放在风口浪尖，告诉他们去应对成年人的政治决策时会发生什么。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Climates Change, People Don't. I met this really great, really smart kid who's into politics this summer. All summer I was watching a lot of Glenn Beck, and I went to that rally that he had in Washington D.C. And so I'm at the rally and I'm wandering around, and I'm talking to people in the crowd.
第二幕，气候变化，人不变。今年夏天我遇到了一个非常棒、非常聪明的孩子，她对政治很感兴趣。整个夏天我都在看很多格伦·贝克的节目，我去参加了他在华盛顿特区举行的集会。所以我在集会上四处闲逛，和人群中的人们交谈。
How old are you guys?
你们多大了？
I'm 14.
我14岁。
16.
16岁。
Did you want to be here or are you being dragged along?
你们是想来这里，还是被拖过来的？
No, I wanted to be here. I'm the one who watches Glenn Beck every day at five, so.
不，我想来这里。我就是那个每天五点看格伦·贝克节目的人，所以。
That's Erin Gustafson, high school freshman, with her older sister, Sarah, and her mom, Michelle. They've driven up from the Shenandoah Valley in Virginia for the rally.
那是艾琳·古斯塔夫森，高一学生，和她姐姐莎拉以及妈妈米歇尔在一起。她们从弗吉尼亚州的谢南多厄河谷开车来参加集会。
Why do you like Glenn Beck so much? What do you like about his show?
为什么你这么喜欢格伦·贝克？你喜欢他的节目什么？
Well, for me it's like a jumping off point. And I know that it's an opinion show, but I will hear what he says and the history behind it, and then from there I can do my own research.
嗯，对我来说，这就像一个跳板。我知道这是一个观点节目，但我会听他说的话和他背后的历史，然后从那里我可以做我自己的研究。
We talked about the kinds of things that you talk about at a Glenn Beck rally. is the President a socialist? The Gustafsons don't think he is. Are they alarmed over the direction the country's going in? They definitely are. They are free market, small government types-- against saving big banks, against the deficit. And then I got on the subject of global warming with 14 year old Erin.
我们谈论了你在格伦·贝克集会上会谈论的那类事情。总统是社会主义者吗？古斯塔夫森一家不认为他是。他们对国家的发展方向感到震惊吗？他们绝对是。他们是自由市场、小政府的拥护者——反对拯救大银行，反对赤字。然后我与14岁的艾琳谈到了全球变暖的话题。
Global warming is propaganda. That's what I believe.
全球变暖是宣传。这就是我的信仰。
Do they teach you that in school? About global warming, I mean?
他们在学校教你这个吗？我是说关于全球变暖？
Yes, they teach you about global warming.
是的，他们教你关于全球变暖的知识。
Do you argue with your teachers?
你和老师争论吗？
Not openly. I try and keep it respectful. And I will answer just by, this is what the book says, I may not agree with it, but this is what the book says, so this is what I have to answer.
不会公开争论。我尽量保持尊重。我会这样回答：这是书上说的，我可能不同意，但这是书上写的，所以这就是我必须回答的内容。
The number of Americans who believe that global warming is real has fallen, and the decline is dramatic. Back in 2006, according to a Pew Research Center study, 79% of the public said there's solid evidence that the Earth is getting warmer. In just three years, the number fell to 57%. Other polls show a similar drop.
相信全球变暖是真实存在的美国人数量已经下降，而且下降幅度非常剧烈。回溯到2006年，根据皮尤研究中心的一项研究，79%的公众表示有确凿证据表明地球正在变暖。仅仅三年后，这一数字下降到了57%。其他民意调查也显示出类似的下降。
So climate change activists and scientists are trying to turn it around in a bunch of different ways, and part of that fight is in the classroom. They want to win over kids Erin's age. The National Science Foundation and NASA are each developing curricula to teach climate change in schools. Meanwhile, on the other side of the fight, bills have been introduced in Kentucky, Oklahoma, and passed in South Dakota-- Texas, by the way, has this too-- urging teachers to teach both sides in the climate change debate. The South Dakota bill declared carbon dioxide is not a pollutant, but rather a highly beneficial ingredient for all plant life.
所以气候变化活动家和科学家正试图通过各种不同的方式来扭转局面，而这场战斗的一部分就在教室里。他们想赢得艾琳这个年龄段的孩子。国家科学基金会和美国国家航空航天局都在开发在学校教授气候变化的课程。与此同时，在战斗的另一方，肯塔基州、俄克拉荷马州提出了法案，南达科他州已经通过了——顺便说一下，德克萨斯州也有这个——敦促教师在气候变化辩论中教授双方的观点。南达科他州的法案宣布二氧化碳不是污染物，而是所有植物生命的一种非常有益的成分。
And with that fight for the hearts and minds of people like Erin and all of her peers in mind, we booked Erin into a studio last week at public radio station WMRA in Virginia.
考虑到那场为像艾琳和她所有的同龄人的心灵而进行的战斗，我们上周安排艾琳去了弗吉尼亚州公共广播电台WMRA的一个录音室。
One, two three. Hey, Erin?
一，二，三。嘿，艾琳？
Hello.
你好。
Hey, Erin, it's Ira.
嘿，艾琳，我是艾拉。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi. How are you?
嗨。你好吗？
I'm wonderful, and yourself?
我好极了，你呢？
At the same time that we had her, we had in a studio in Colorado, at public radio station KGHU, a scientist named Roberta Johnson who develops curricula as Executive Director of the National Earth Science Teacher Association, and who studies the climate at the National Center for Atmospheric Research.
在我们邀请她的同时，我们在科罗拉多州公共广播电台KGHU的一个录音室里，邀请了一位名叫罗伯塔·约翰逊的科学家，她是国家地球科学教师协会的执行主任，专门负责开发课程，并在国家大气研究中心研究气候。
OK, so Dr. Johnson, meet Erin.
好的，那么约翰逊博士，见见艾琳。
Hi Erin.
嗨，艾琳。
Hello, Dr. Johnson.
你好，约翰逊博士。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Dr. Johnson and Erin Gustafson agreed to come into the studio to do a little experiment that we proposed to both of them. Dr. Johnson would run through the very best material that she thinks teachers have to convince students that global warming is real. And Erin would tell her and us if it was convincing, if it won her over. Was there anything a scientist could say to convince a kid who's already skeptical?
约翰逊博士和艾琳·古斯塔夫森同意来到录音室，做一个我们向他们双方提议的小实验。约翰逊博士将列举她认为教师们拥有的最优秀的材料，来说服学生全球变暖是真实的。而艾琳将告诉她和我们这是否令人信服，是否赢得了她的信任。有没有什么科学家能说的话可以说服一个已经持怀疑态度的孩子？
Up until now, Erin says, her schools haven't devoted a lot of time to teaching climate change, and it's not really a big subject for Glenn Beck, she says, so most of what she knows is based in her own curiosity, reading she's done poking around the internet. They both actually were pretty psyched for this.
艾琳说，到目前为止，她的学校还没有投入大量时间教授气候变化，而且她说这在格伦·贝克的节目中也不是什么大课题，所以她所知道的大部分内容是基于她自己的好奇心，以及她在互联网上闲逛时所做的阅读。他们俩实际上对这次尝试都相当兴奋。
So Dr. Johnson, we can't give you a full semester here on the radio to walk through all of the arguments one might do, but you're going to lay out some of this case for Erin. And I understand you're going to break this down into two parts. So can you walk through the first part of your presentation?
所以约翰逊博士，我们不能给你一个完整的学期在广播里来讲解所有的论点，但你将为艾琳列出部分案例。据我所知，你要把它分成两部分。那么你能讲解一下你演讲的第一部分吗？
Well, I think the first part is that when we look at measurements taken around the world, we have an overwhelming amount of evidence that the climate is warming. And we know that from the increase in temperature that we observe in the land, the oceans, and the sea. We know that ice and snow cover are decreasing. Permafrost is thawing. Sea level is rising. All of those things are indicators of a warming climate.
嗯，我认为第一部分是，当我们观察世界各地的测量数据时，我们有压倒性的证据表明气候正在变暖。我们从观察到的陆地、海洋和海域温度的升高知道了这一点。我们知道冰雪覆盖正在减少。多年冻土正在解冻。海平面正在上升。所有这些都是气候变暖的指标。
Now, then the question becomes, how do we know that that has an association with carbon dioxide and greenhouse gases? And the other piece of that evidence is that we also know that carbon dioxide is increasing in the atmosphere dramatically.
那么问题就变成了，我们怎么知道这与二氧化碳和温室气体有关联？证据的另一部分是，我们也知道大气中的二氧化碳正在急剧增加。
OK, so that's the first part of your presentation, what's the second part? I understand it has to do with something called ice cores?
好的，这是你演讲的第一部分，第二部分是什么？我知道它与一种叫做冰芯的东西有关？
Yeah, so there's these really cool ice cores-- cool, I meant as a pun, actually-- they have drilled these things now for decades in a number of different places-- there's got to be at least 20 or 30 of them that have been drilled in the Antarctic or in Greenland. These things are like two or three inches across, and they drill these things down, and down, and down.
是的，确实有一些非常酷的冰芯——酷，我实际上是在玩双关语——他们现在已经在许多不同的地方钻探这些东西几十年了——在南极洲或格陵兰岛钻探的至少有20或30个。这些东西直径有两三英寸，他们一直向下、向下、向下钻探。
And each ice core records a nice annual record of the temperature, the atmospheric composition. It gathers dust, it gathers volcanic debris. So they take these things out, they take them back to laboratories, and they can analyze them. And those records show very clearly temperature and CO2 have been very closely correlated for over 420,000 years. So as temperature goes up, CO2 goes up. And what we know is that the overall oscillation in temperature and CO2--
每一个冰芯都记录了很好的温度、大气成分的年度记录。它收集灰尘，收集火山碎片。所以他们取出这些东西，带回实验室，进行分析。这些记录非常清晰地显示，在超过42万年的时间里，温度和二氧化碳一直保持着非常密切的相关性。所以当温度上升时，二氧化碳也会上升。而我们所知道的是，温度和二氧化碳的整体振荡——
OK, at this point Dr. Johnson got into some details that both Erin and I took awhile to grasp, so I'm going to just summarize for you to move things along. Basically, Roberta Johnson was saying we can explain the way temperature and carbon dioxide rose and fell over 420,000 years by looking at how the Earth was tilting-- its position relative to the sun.
好的，在这一点上，约翰逊博士进入了一些艾琳和我都需要一段时间才能领会的技术细节，所以为了推进进度，我将为你总结一下。基本上，罗伯塔·约翰逊的意思是，我们可以通过观察地球是如何倾斜的——相对于太阳的位置——来解释温度和二氧化碳在42万年里是如何上升和下降的。
When the Earth would wobble towards the sun, there'd be more heat and carbon dioxide. When the Earth would wobble away a little bit, less heat, less carbon dioxide. It all matched up until now. Just based on the Earth's tilt and orientation, the amount of carbon dioxide in the atmosphere should now be a lot lower than it is. We are 35% higher than we should be. What's the cause? The logical culprit, she says, is human beings and the machines we've made that spew carbon dioxide-- CO2.
当地球向太阳倾斜时，会有更多的热量和二氧化碳。当地球稍微向后倾斜一点时，热量更少，二氧化碳更少。这一切直到现在都吻合。仅基于地球的倾斜和方位，大气中的二氧化碳量现在应该比实际低得多。我们比应该有的水平高出了35%。原因是什么？她说，逻辑上的罪魁祸首是人类以及我们制造的喷出二氧化碳（CO2）的机器。
You can analyze the CO2 itself, and that's what scientists have done. And they've found that the carbon in the carbon dioxide gas is lighter in its isotopic ratio than it should be if it was from a natural source. So what that tells us is that there's a direct tie from the CO2 we're seeing to a fossil fuel source.
你可以分析二氧化碳本身，这就是科学家们所做的。他们发现二氧化碳气体中的碳在其同位素比例上比它如果是来自自然源时要轻。所以这告诉我们的是，我们所看到的二氧化碳与化石燃料来源之间存在直接联系。
OK, so I feel like some of this has gotten actually a little bit technical. So Erin, before I ask you if any of this is convincing, I want to ask you, do you have questions about any of this?
好的，我觉得其中一些内容变得确实有点技术性了。所以艾琳，在我问你这些内容是否有说服力之前，我想问你，你对这些内容有疑问吗？
I think I understand most of it, so I'm going to go with no.
我想我理解大部分内容，所以我打算说没有。
OK, that's the way I feel too, I feel like I understand most of it. And so, Erin, do you find any of this convincing?
好的，这也是我的感觉，我觉得我理解大部分内容。所以艾琳，你觉得其中任何一点有说服力吗？
Not particularly, not any more than what I've previously read.
不特别觉得，没有比我之前读到的更令人信服。
How come?
为什么？
Because I feel like there are still holes in the theory. Like the arguments that the highest temperatures that they've discovered have been in the 12th century. And that the satellite images that have taken, that have shown the shrinking of the ice caps, were not entirely correct. And that they've taken other pictures that show that there isn't nearly as much melting as they thought.
因为我觉得这个理论中仍然存在漏洞。比如他们发现的最高温度是在12世纪的论点。而且那些被拍到的、显示冰盖缩小的卫星图像并不完全准确。而且他们还拍了其他照片，显示融化的情况远没有他们想象的那么严重。
What Erin's talking about are arguments against global warming that you read. That the Earth got really warm back in the 12th century, and it wasn't greenhouse gasses causing that-- maybe that's just happening again. And that satellite photos showed Arctic ice melting in one set of photos, but in another, didn't look so bad. She also asked, why have winters been colder and snowfall greater, if climate change is already, supposedly, taking effect. And she very delicately asked Dr. Johnson about Climategate.
艾琳所说的是你读到的反对全球变暖的论点。地球在12世纪变得非常温暖，而且那不是温室气体导致的——也许那只是再次发生而已。而且卫星照片在这一组照片中显示北极冰层融化，但在另一组照片中看起来并没有那么糟糕。她还问，如果气候变化已经据说开始生效，为什么冬天变得更冷，降雪量更大？她还非常谨慎地向约翰逊博士询问了气候门事件。
Well, if we've learned so much about-- I'm sorry if this comes off as, with the way I started that, as disrespectful-- but if we've learned so much about this--
嗯，如果我们已经学到了这么多关于——很抱歉，如果这听起来像是我开始的那样不尊重——但如果我们已经学到了这么多关于这个的内容——
One by one, Dr. Johnson answered each of these questions. Yes, it got warmer in the 12th century, but for reasons that we can name, and it was nowhere near as warm as today. Yes, it might be colder in any given winter, but that is just the randomness of weather, that's not the climate. Yes, there's more snow now, because a warmer planet means more water vapor trapped in the atmosphere, which means storms of all kinds become more intense including snow. Yes, climate scientists said some things in their stolen emails that might seem at first to be damning, but several different commissions working independently all verified that they did not tamper with the data or the peer review process. Yes, the Arctic ice in photos might fluctuate, but the overall trend is clear.
约翰逊博士一一回答了每一个问题。是的，12世纪确实变暖了，但原因是我们能说出来的，而且远没有今天这么热。是的，在任何特定的冬天可能会更冷，但这只是天气的随机性，不是气候。是的，现在雪更多了，因为地球变暖意味着大气中锁住更多的水蒸气，这意味着各种风暴变得更加剧烈，包括降雪。是的，气候科学家在他们被盗的电子邮件中说了一些起初可能看起来很令人震惊的话，但几个独立工作的委员会都验证了他们没有篡改数据或同行评审过程。是的，照片中的北极冰层可能会波动，但总体趋势很明确。
So, Erin, this explanation of what happened in the satellite pictures, do you find that credible, convincing, does this change your picture of it-- what the doctor is saying?
所以，艾琳，这个关于卫星照片中发生了什么的解释，你觉得可信、令人信服吗？这改变了你对它的看法吗——医生说的话？
I can see where there would then be discrepancies between the sets of pictures, but, meh.
我能看出这些照片集之间确实会存在差异，但是，呃。
You don't sound won over.
听起来你并没有被说服。
I wouldn't say that I'm won over, it's just it opens more questions.
我不会说我被说服了，这只是提出了更多问题。
Erin, do you feel like any of the arguments that Dr. Johnson makes-- about the 12th century, about these satellite pictures, on any of these subjects-- is the way that you hear, you feel like, well, sure, that's a perfectly good argument, but you're just getting one side of the picture, and that there's another side too?
艾琳，你觉得约翰逊博士提出的任何论点——关于12世纪，关于这些卫星照片，在这些话题上的任何一个——是不是你听到的时候，你会觉得，嗯，当然，这是一个非常好的论点，但你只是看到了画面的一面，还有另一面？
Yes, that is pretty close. And it's like, I get that climate does flux and change, and that we as people affect the climate. But it's all kind of back and forth, because you can find plenty of examples to go with global warming, or climate change, and then a lot to go against it.
是的，这很接近。这就像，我明白气候确实会波动和变化，而且我们作为人会影响气候。但这一切都是来回往复的，因为你可以找到很多例子来支持全球变暖或气候变化，然后有很多来反对它。
You feel you feel you're caught up in a kind of a he said, she said argument?
你觉得自己陷入了一种“公说公有理，婆说婆有理”的争论中吗？
Kind of, yes.
算是吧，是的。
But Dr. Johnson, from your point of view, you don't feel like this is something where, OK, there's two sides to this argument. You feel like the data is in and we have an answer now?
但约翰逊博士，从你的角度来看，你不觉得这是一个——嗯，关于这个争论有两方看法的问题。你觉得数据已经到位，我们现在有了答案？
Yes, I do. My point is that this is really not a question of belief. This is a question of science. We look at the evidence, we use our scientific knowledge, and we come to science based conclusions.
是的，我确实这么认为。我的观点是，这实际上不是一个信仰的问题。这是一个科学的问题。我们查看证据，我们使用我们的科学知识，我们得出基于科学的结论。
Hey, Erin, is there anything that any science teacher could say that could convince you of this?
嘿，艾琳，有没有什么科学老师说的话可以说服你接受这一点？
Quite possibly. If I saw both sides of the argument, arguing for both for and against global warming-- see those two arguments, completely side by side, laid out, then maybe I could see how it would be true. Or even, more definitely, how it isn't true.
很有可能。如果我看到争论双方，支持和反对全球变暖的论点——看到这两个论点完全并排地列出来，那么也许我能看到它可能是真的。或者，更明确地，它是如何不真实的。
I just personally feel like this is kind of almost like evolution. Where you'll have people who will say that, yes, this is fact, and this is what happened. And then there'll be other people who will say, this is theory, it could go one way, it could go the other. And then there'll be the people who say that this is completely untrue.
我个人觉得这几乎就像进化论。有些人会说，是的，这是事实，这就是发生的事情。然后会有其他人会说，这是理论，它可能朝一个方向发展，也可能朝另一个方向发展。然后会有完全不相信的人。
Dr. Johnson, can I ask you-- I feel like the question this seems like it points to from your side of this-- and I hope you feel like you can answer this honestly-- is do you think it's hopeless to reach certain people once they're already skeptical? Once someone is skeptical of this and they see it as a he said, she said argument, is it possible to ever get through to them?
约翰逊博士，我可以问你吗——我感觉从你的立场来看，这个问题似乎是指向——我希望你能诚实地回答这个问题——你认为一旦人们已经持怀疑态度，去触及他们是否是绝望的？一旦有人对此持怀疑态度，并且他们认为这是一个“公说公有理，婆说婆有理”的争论，有可能真正说服他们吗？
Well, we're certainly going to keep trying. I think there's only so far you can go. I do tend to think that unfortunately-- you know, there's a spectrum of belief-- I have to remain hopeful that when people have open minds and are equipped to analyze evidence, that they'll come to rational conclusions.
嗯，我们当然会继续尝试。我认为你只能做到这一步。我确实倾向于认为，不幸的是——你知道，存在一个信仰光谱——我必须保持希望，当人们有开放的心态并有能力分析证据时，他们会得出合理的结论。
[MUSIC - "FREEDOM OF CHOICE" BY DEVO]
[音乐 - 迪沃乐队的“选择的自由”]
Act Three, Minor Authorities. What if you ran a school and you had the kids vote and decide on all the rules? They decide on all the discipline, decide which classes should be taught, what would happen if you don't show up for class, can you nap in school. Not to be harsh, but what if the inmates ran the asylum?
第三幕，微小权威。如果你经营一所学校，让孩子们投票决定所有规则会怎样？他们决定所有的纪律，决定应该教哪些课程，如果你不来上课会发生什么，你可以在学校小睡吗？不是要严厉，但如果由犯人来经营疯人院呢？
Well, there's a movement in alternative education called the free school movement. Typically there are no courses. Each kid studies what he or she wants independently. At The Brooklyn Free School, for instance, a teacher can offer a class, or the kids can vote for some class they want created. There are no tests, no homework, there aren't even grade levels-- you know, first grade, second grade, all that. And the kids decide everything about how the school is run.
嗯，替代教育中有一场运动叫自由学校运动。通常没有课程。每个孩子独立学习他或她想要的东西。例如，在布鲁克林自由学校，老师可以提供一门课程，或者孩子们可以投票决定创建他们想要的课程。没有考试，没有家庭作业，甚至没有年级——你知道，一年级，二年级，所有这些。而孩子们决定关于学校如何运作的一切。
If this sounds nuts, you should know that since The Brooklyn Free School was started seven years ago, nearly all its graduates have gone on to normal accredited colleges. We wanted to see what happens when the kids make all the decisions, so we headed over to The Brooklyn Free School.
如果这听起来很疯狂，你应该知道，自从布鲁克林自由学校七年前创办以来，几乎所有的毕业生都进入了正常的认证大学。我们想看看当孩子们做出所有决定时会发生什么，所以我们去了布鲁克林自由学校。
First agenda item is This American Life.
第一个议程是《美国生活》。
Naturally, to record at the school, we had to get permission from the authorities there-- the kids themselves.
自然地，为了在学校录音，我们必须获得那里的权威——孩子们自己的许可。
The proposal is that This American Life project goes forward.
提议是让《美国生活》项目继续进行。
OK.
好的。
I second.
我附议。
I third.
我投第三票。
Glad we got that six year old on our side there. We're in the school gym, it's about 50 kids, which is the whole school, age four to 19. A mix of kids who didn't do well in other schools, some behavior problem kids, some kids of professionals and crunchy parents. It's actually very diverse. There's a short discussion about whether they want to have us in the school.
很高兴我们争取到了那个六岁孩子站在我们这边。我们在学校体育馆里，大约有50个孩子，也就是全校的学生，年龄从四岁到19岁。这是一群在其他学校表现不佳的孩子、一些有行为问题的孩子、以及一些专业人士和追求前卫父母的孩子。实际上非常多元。关于是否想让我们进入学校，有一个简短的讨论。
I don't mean to be a pain about it. I don't know, I just don't really see the whole point of being on the radio if nothing really exciting is going to happen.
我不是故意要添麻烦。我不知道，如果真的不会发生什么令人兴奋的事情，我只是不觉得上电台有什么意义。
After a few minutes, there's a vote.
几分钟后，进行了投票。
OK, all for? 38. All against? One, two. OK, so that's two against. And all abstain? That's three? Or four. OK, so that passes.
好的，赞成的？38。反对的？一，二。好的，那是两个反对。弃权的？那是三个？或者四个。好的，所以通过了。
And because that passed, Jyllian Gunther has this story.
而且因为通过了，吉莲·冈瑟有了这个故事。
Meetings are so central to The Brooklyn Free School that the only requirement at the school besides showing up is that once a week you attend what is known as the all school democratic meeting. But there are other meetings too. Meetings for teens, meetings for younger kids, impromptu meetings.
会议在布鲁克林自由学校是如此核心，以至于除了到校之外，学校唯一的规定是每周参加一次所谓的全校民主会议。但还有其他会议。青少年会议、幼童会议、即兴会议。
Meetings can be called by anyone, and they are-- sometimes as many as six a day. At times it can feel like a constant session of Congress, which is by design. Free schools are modeled after our country's approach to government. Give each person a vote and the collective decisions will be what's best for everyone.
会议可以由任何人召集，而且确实如此——有时一天多达六次。有时它会让人觉得是一场持续不断的国会会议，这是设计使然。自由学校是模仿我们国家的政府方式建立的。给每个人投票权，集体的决定就会是对每个人最好的。
So how does it work when the voters are kids? There was the meeting where the whole school decided that a boy who was always acting out should get constant supervision, so kids signed up for hourly shifts to watch him and keep him in line. Or the one where the kids called a meeting on the school's director for eating in a no food zone. Or the time a student called a meeting-- get this-- on herself for missing too many days of school. She was asked by her peers to present a case for why she shouldn't be kicked out of school.
那么当选民是孩子时，它是如何运作的呢？曾有一次会议，全校决定让一个总是胡闹的男孩接受持续监督，所以孩子们报名参加每小时的轮班来看着他，让他守规矩。或者是孩子们因学校主管在无饮食区吃东西而召集的会议。或者有一次一名学生因旷课太多而召集了关于她自己的会议——听好了。她被同学们要求陈述理由，解释为什么不应该把她开除。
I happen to know all this because my close friend Katherine is a co-founder and social worker at the school. The first thing you notice about The Brooklyn Free School, it doesn't look anything like a school. It's a five story brownstone. The gym used to be the living room, the dining room is a library, a former bathroom is the band room. There's an art room and a handful of classrooms, which all look like a cross between a preschool and a teenager's rec room. In the teen lounge, teenagers lie on the floor reading The Brothers Karamazov out loud.
我碰巧知道这一切，因为我的密友凯瑟琳是学校的联合创始人兼社工。你对布鲁克林自由学校注意到的第一件事是，它看起来一点也不像学校。这是一栋五层楼的褐砂石建筑。体育馆以前是客厅，餐厅是图书馆，前浴室是乐队室。有一个艺术室和几间教室，看起来都像学前班和青少年娱乐室的结合体。在青少年休息室里，青少年躺在地上大声朗读《卡拉马佐夫兄弟》。
It is well known that there were frequent fights between husband and wife, but according to tradition.
众所周知，丈夫和妻子之间经常吵架，但根据传统。
Some other kids go to the store to buy Tic Tacs. Some kids are playing cards. On the second floor, Kai was bothering Martin and the younger kids are having a meeting to resolve it.
其他一些孩子去商店买薄荷糖。有些孩子在玩牌。在二楼，凯在打扰马丁，年纪较小的孩子们正在开会解决这个问题。
If you do it again, we're going to call an all school meeting, come up with a consequence. So don't do it again.
如果你再这样做，我们要召开全校会议，想出一个后果。所以不要再这样做了。
The first few meetings I watched were not impressive. One Wednesday I went to an all school meeting. The topic of the day was the art room.
我观看的前几次会议并不令人印象深刻。一个周三，我参加了一个全校会议。当天的议题是艺术室。
Art room. What's the proposal?
艺术室。提议是什么？
Specifically, the age old problem of kids making a mess and not cleaning up. There was a long debate about how to fix this, some proposals, and a lot of finger pointing. The kids mostly seem bored. An hour later, nothing was decided and the meeting was adjourned. To me, the whole thing just looked like a waste of time. I wondered how much math, and science, and reading could these kids be doing instead of all these meetings?
具体来说，是孩子们制造混乱且不清理的老大难问题。关于如何解决这个问题有一场漫长的辩论，一些提议，还有很多指责。孩子们大多数看起来很无聊。一小时后，什么也没决定，会议休会了。对我来说，这一切看起来只是在浪费时间。我想知道这些孩子本可以做多少数学、科学和阅读，而不是参加这些会议？
I needed to see more, and I did. Over a month I saw all kinds of meetings at the school, and the one that really tested the question, if kids are in charge, do they make the best decisions, was the meeting about the no screens week rule.
我需要看到更多，我也确实看到了。在一个月里，我看到了学校里各种各样的会议，而真正考验这个问题——如果孩子掌权，他们会做出最好的决定吗——的会议是关于“无屏幕周”规则的会议。
OK, so Ari, you're the chair, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE], you're the co-chair.
好的，那么阿里，你是主席，以及[听不清]，你是联合主席。
To understand the no screens week rule, you should know that for the staff it's a badge of honor. A few years ago, the entire school outlawed using any electronic device with a screen. No computers, no cell phones, no video games. The kids thought they were too distracting. The little ones were addicted. And so to break the addiction, every other week would be a no screens week, and if you wanted to get on a computer to do some research on a no screens week, you needed special permission from a staff member, which was a hassle. At a teens only meeting, a 15 year old named Malia dropped this bomb.
要理解“无屏幕周”规则，你应该知道这对教职员工来说是一种荣誉徽章。几年前，全校禁止使用任何带屏幕的电子设备。没有电脑，没有手机，没有电子游戏。孩子们认为它们太分散注意力了。小一点的孩子上瘾了。所以为了戒除这种瘾，每隔一周就是无屏幕周，如果你想在无屏幕周用电脑做研究，你需要教职人员的特别许可，这很麻烦。在一个仅限青少年的会议上，一个名叫马莉亚的15岁女孩投下了这枚炸弹。
Malia?
马莉亚？
So I was thinking we take down no screens week for like, I'm thinking people like 13 and older. I just think that we need to be able to work and do what research we need to, so that's like a proposal or whatever.
所以我一直在想，我们取消无屏幕周，比如针对13岁及以上的人。我只是认为我们需要能够工作并做我们需要的研究，所以这是一个提议或者什么的。
I second that.
我附议。
I third that.
我投第三票。
I don't.
我不。
Order. Order!
秩序。秩序！
The no screens rule has been challenged before, but never successfully. Those in favor were quick to speak up, like [? Aran, ?] a 19 year old in an evolution t-shirt depicting a monkey, a human, and a robot.
无屏幕规则以前被挑战过，但从未成功。赞成的人很快就发言了，比如[？阿兰？]，一个穿着绘有猴子、人类和机器人进化的T恤的19岁男孩。
Yeah, ?] I think it's pathetic basically. I mean, with the no screens week, basically when you do research, you're breaking a rule. School is for learning, and it's so pathetic that when you do research-- I mean it should be encouraged, but it's so pathetic that when you do research you break a rule. So I think this should just be totally gone with.
是的，我认为这基本上很可悲。我的意思是，有了无屏幕周，基本上当你做研究时，你就违反了规则。学校是为了学习，而当你做研究时——我的意思是它应该被鼓励，但当你做研究时你违反规则，这太可悲了。所以我认为这应该彻底废除。
The adults don't agree, they want the restriction on the screens to stay. But they're outnumbered by the kids by a three to one margin. Lily, a teacher at the school, tries to rein them in.
成年人不同意，他们希望保持对屏幕的限制。但孩子们以三比一的比例在人数上压倒了他们。学校老师莉莉试图约束他们。
I was a teacher and an adviser of the high school when we made this rule, and there was a lot of conversation about the positive things that it would bring for highschoolers. We also talked a lot about the effects that a lot of screen time has on sleep, which is a huge thing for people your age, and we talk about that a lot in attendance meeting. So I wanted to bring that up some.
我在我们制定这条规则时是高中的老师和顾问，关于它给高中生带来的积极影响有很多讨论。我们还讨论了很多屏幕时间对睡眠的影响，这对你们这个年龄的人来说是一件大事，我们在考勤会上经常讨论那个。所以我只是想提一下那个。
And then also, I just wanted to say that, of course, no screens week doesn't mean no research, and sometimes you can do better research without a screen.
还有，我也想说，当然，无屏幕周并不意味着没有研究，有时你可以在没有屏幕的情况下做更好的研究。
Is that it? [? Aram, ?] [? Aran, ?] whatever.
就是这样吗？[？阿兰？][？阿兰？]随便吧。
Aran. ?]
阿兰。[？]
Yeah, ?] first of all, I have some things to say. In response to what Lily said, even though screen may not be the only way to research, it definitely is the easiest way to research. I mean, the internet you can get more information than from a book. That is definitely the truth-- I mean, a book you have to like look, look, look, the internet, you can just search, so yeah--
是的，首先，我有几件事要说。针对莉莉说的话，即使屏幕可能不是做研究的唯一方式，它绝对是做研究的最简单方式。我的意思是，互联网比书本能得到更多信息。那绝对是事实——我的意思是，书你得看、看、看，互联网，你可以直接搜索，所以是的——
I should say here, as the meeting is happening, two kids are texting and one is playing a game on his Nintendo DS, which is fine, it is a screens week. [? Aram, ?] 12, is Malia's younger brother, and he thinks his sister's proposal is risky.
我应该在这里说一下，当会议进行时，两个孩子在发短信，一个在玩他的任天堂DS游戏机，这没关系，那是屏幕周。[？阿兰？]，12岁，是马莉亚的弟弟，他认为他姐姐的提议有风险。
I ?] don't know how many of you were students here when-- it was like two years ago-- that no screens week was taken down for like a three week time period. And it was like really chaotic. No one did anything. The only thing anyone did was just sit there using screens.
我不知道你们有多少人是这里的学生，当时——那是大约两年前——无屏幕周被取消了大约三周。那真的很混乱。没有人做什么。大家做的唯一事情就是坐在那里用屏幕。
Then a student says that all this is besides the point, because the rule itself is completely inconsistent with the school's philosophy. If you can trust someone to learn what they need to know without encouraging them, shouldn't you trust them to know when to turn a computer off? After 20 minutes of debate, a vote is taken. Six people abstain, three people vote against, 11 for.
然后一个学生说这一切都无关紧要，因为规则本身与学校的理念完全不一致。如果你能信任某人去学习他们需要知道的东西而不鼓励他们，难道你不应该信任他们知道什么时候关掉电脑吗？经过20分钟的辩论，进行了投票。六个人弃权，三个人投反对票，11个人赞成。
It passes.
通过了。
Yes!
耶！
Wow.
哇。
Yay.
噢耶。
The result of this meaning-- all screens, all the time-- is this an example of kids knowing what's best for them? Seems like a potential disaster to me and every other adult in the room. And right after the meeting, when I ask [? Aran, ?] the kid who was most vocal about needing his computer to do research, he confided, well, he'd also be playing some video games. A few weeks later, I check in with Lily, a teacher who'd voted against the policy to find out how things were going.
这次会议的结果——所有的屏幕，一直使用——这是孩子们知道什么对他们最好的例子吗？对我来说，这和屋子里的其他成年人一样，看起来像一场潜在的灾难。会议结束后，当我问[？阿兰？]——那个对需要电脑做研究呼声最高的孩子——他吐露说，好吧，他也会玩一些电子游戏。几周后，我向投票反对这项政策的老师莉莉询问情况进展如何。
Everyone's been really responsible. There're very few students who have changed how much they use screens since before that was passed. I think it's an interesting thing when you give them that permission, I guess, or that responsibility, like, OK, you're voting this through, you're all making this decision, you know, you're all saying, we can handle this.
每个人都非常负责。自那通过以来，只有很少学生改变了他们使用屏幕的数量。我认为当你给他们那种许可，或者那种责任时，这是一件有趣的事情，就像，好的，你们投票通过了这个，你们都在做这个决定，你知道，你们都在说，我们可以处理好这个。
And I think that a lot of the teenagers have been very careful not to cause any problems since that rule got passed, because they know it's something that they put their stamp on. Like technically, there could be movies played all day long now, every single day, but they're not.
而且我认为很多青少年非常小心，自从那条规则通过以来没有引起任何问题，因为他们知道这是他们自己盖章的东西。就像技术上，现在可能每天、整天都在播放电影，但他们没有。
Which means the system's working, for now.
这意味着系统目前在运作。
Late one Wednesday near the end of school everyone's cleaning up and getting ready to leave, and suddenly word goes up and down the stairs that someone's calling an impromptu all school meeting, a big deal in the arsenal of democratic meetings. Anyone can interrupt the whole school at any time and hold court.
快学期末的一个周三深夜，大家都在打扫卫生准备离开，突然楼上楼下传来消息说有人要召集即兴的全校会议，这是民主会议军火库里的一件大事。任何人都可以随时打断全校并开庭。
Who called this meeting and why? Malia?
谁召集了这个会议，为什么？马莉亚？
I called this meaning because someone said something that is not appropriate to me again.
我召集这个会议是因为又有人说了不该对我说的、不合适的话。
Confusion sets in. A 10 year old says, "I don't think you should waste our time on this, it's crazy to call this meeting." And another student asks, "Why not call a smaller meeting with whoever did it?" Despite the fact that I heard a lot from Malia in the short time I was at school, she's not known for calling meetings or crying wolf. Malia says it's about two brothers, [? Cruz ?] and [? Seoul. ?]
困惑开始了。一个10岁的孩子说：“我不认为你应该在这上面浪费我们的时间，召集这个会议太疯狂了。”另一名学生问：“为什么不和做那事的人召开一个更小的会议？”尽管在我呆在学校的短暂时间里我从马莉亚那里听到了很多，但她并不以召集会议或谎报军情而闻名。马莉亚说这是关于两兄弟，[？克鲁兹？]和[？首尔？]。
Because I want to show [? Cruz ?] and [? Seoul ?] that this is an important-- that this is not something that they can just do. You cannot say a bad word to someone and just get away with it. So I'm making it an all school thing now.
因为我想向[？克鲁兹？]和[？首尔？]展示这是一件重要的——这不是他们可以随便做的事情。你不能对别人说坏话然后就这么算了。所以我现在把它变成全校的事情。
Infinity?
无限？
What did they say to you of that was so bad?
他们对你说了什么那么糟糕的话？
Was that a direct question? They called me a whore, both of them, like twice. I mean, I didn't even do anything to them. I asked them to stop annoying me and Bennett because we are talking quietly in the library, and they came up and they said, oh, whatever, you're a whore, or whatever.
那是一个直接的问题吗？他们叫我妓女，他们俩都叫了，大约两次。我的意思是，我甚至没对他们做什么。我只是让他们别打扰我和本内特，因为我们在图书馆安静地交谈，他们走过来就说，哦，不管怎样，你是个妓女，或者什么的。
[? Kirren? ?]
[？基伦？]
What ?] the hell is a whore?
什么是妓女？
That's [? Kirren, ?] seven. He and everyone else look over at [? Cruz ?] and [? Seoul ?] waiting for an answer, but [? Cruz ?] is only just nine himself, and [? Seoul ?] is 10. And sitting in Katherine's lap, the brothers appear even younger than they are, and they look a little lost and embarrassed. Katherine breaks the silence.
那是[？基伦？]，七岁。他和所有人一样看向[？克鲁兹？]和[？首尔？]等待答案，但[？克鲁兹？]自己才刚九岁，[？首尔？]是10岁。坐在凯瑟琳的怀里，兄弟俩看起来比实际年龄还要小，他们看起来有点迷茫和尴尬。凯瑟琳打破了沉默。
I'd love for [? Seoul ?] and [? Cruz ?] to talk right now, but they also don't know what the word means. And it doesn't matter what the word means, but it was very offensive and upsetting to Malia, and I'm glad you brought this up, Malia.
我真的很想让[？首尔？]和[？克鲁兹？]现在说话，但他们也不知道这个词的意思。无论那个词是什么意思都不重要，但这对马莉亚来说是非常冒犯和令人不安的，我很高兴你提到了这一点，马莉亚。
Malia offers a tasteful and purposefully vague explanation of the word whore. The kids get that the word is bad. While it's clear that Malia's angry, it's not entirely clear what the purpose of the meeting is. Does she want them punished? Does she want an apology? Lily tries to gently steer Malia to a conclusion.
马莉亚提供了一个高雅且特意模糊的关于“妓女”这个词的解释。孩子们明白那个词不好。虽然很明显马莉亚很生气，但会议的目的是什么并不完全清楚。她想要他们受罚吗？她想要一个道歉吗？莉莉试图轻轻地引导马莉亚得出一个结论。
I wondered, Malia, what you are hoping to get out of this. If it would be helpful, do you think, to maybe talk in a smaller meeting with them after this? Or if there's something else that you're looking for?
我想知道，马莉亚，你希望从这次会议中得到什么。如果你觉得有帮助，你认为在这次会议之后也许和他们进行一次更小的会议谈谈怎么样？或者如果你还在寻找其他什么东西？
I didn't really come with the idea of a proposal, I just think that when people do something wrong, they need to see that it's something bigger than just them. But I think it needs to stop. People don't know what they're saying, and they say it all the time, and that's not even a good way to use the word. It's like, if you're going to use the word, don't just use it when you don't know what it is randomly.
我并没有带着提案的想法来，我只是认为当人们做错事时，他们需要看到这是一件比他们自己更大的事情。但我认为它需要停止。人们不知道自己在说什么，他们一直这么说，那甚至不是使用这个词的好方式。就像，如果你要使用这个词，不要只是在不知道它是什么的时候随机使用它。
Then Malia improvises something remarkable. She turns the focus of the meeting away from herself.
然后马莉亚即兴创作了一些了不起的东西。她把会议的焦点从自己身上转移开了。
And I'd like to ask to see a raise of hands-- I'd like to see how many people have been called something.
我想请大家举手——我想看看有多少人被叫过什么东西。
Nearly every hand in the room goes up.
屋子里几乎每只手都举了起来。
See, it's just so many people. And I think--
看，就是有这么多人。而且我认为——
She asks people to talk about it.
她请大家谈谈这件事。
I think that like a lot of kids do that to me also, and I hate it.
我想很多孩子也会那样对我，我讨厌那样。
We understand that these words are derogatory, so I think we should think of a consequence or proposal next time somebody curses at somebody else.
我们明白这些词是贬义的，所以我认为下次有人咒骂别人时，我们应该想出一个后果或提议。
Whoever the hell made up these curse words was really wrong.
无论谁发明了这些诅咒词，真的错了。
Malia proposes they meet again tomorrow to come up with consequences for calling someone a bad name. They all agree. But they didn't do it. In the end, no new rules went into effect, they didn't even meet. When I found out, I was genuinely surprised. One day, this was a big deal to everyone, the next day forgotten.
马莉亚提议他们明天再见面，想出咒骂别人坏名字的后果。大家都同意了。但他们没做。最后，没有任何新规则生效，他们甚至没见面。当我发现时，我真的感到惊讶。有一天，这对每个人来说都是件大事，第二天就忘记了。
In the weeks I was at the school, a lot of meetings ended this way. One proposal about kids being too noisy outside and bothering the neighbors, a smaller meeting about the democratic meetings themselves and how to improve them, and a bigger meeting where those improvements were struck down all together. Another about kids in the kitchen not eating other kids food. That first meeting I attended about cleaning the art room.
在我呆在学校的几周里，很多会议都以这种方式结束。一个关于孩子在外面太吵、打扰邻居的提议，关于民主会议本身以及如何改进的小型会议，以及一个关于那些改进被全部否决的大型会议。另一个是关于厨房里的孩子不吃其他孩子食物的。我参加的关于打扫艺术室的那第一次会议。
A lot of talk with no conclusion. When I asked my friend Katherine about this, she says that's part of the plan.
谈论了很多，没有结论。当我问我的朋友凯瑟琳时，她说那是计划的一部分。
You know, so what if there's no resolution? The point is they're left with something to think about. What are you going to do about it? You know, that's more interesting to me than somebody deciding that this is the way it should be. And then it's all easier, and it all goes nicer.
你知道，如果没有解决办法又怎样？重点是他们留下了思考的东西。你打算对此做什么？你知道，这对我来说比有人决定这就是应该的方式更有趣。然后一切都更容易，一切都进行得更好。
When I see Malia a few days later, I ask her what happened. Why no follow-up meeting? She explains, another meeting wasn't necessary. She'd said what she had to, everyone listened, other people spoke up too, and she feels better.
几天后我见到马莉亚时，问她发生了什么。为什么没有后续会议？她解释说，不需要再开会了。她已经说了她必须说的话，每个人都听了，其他人也发言了，她感觉好多了。
And it was kind of different from in a real school, you'd say, I have a problem, and then you get a teacher to deal with it. Or instead of everybody getting together and saying that this is a big problem, and that everybody should deal with it, and we should work together to change it.
这和在真正的学校里有点不同，你会说，我有一个问题，然后你让老师处理。或者而不是每个人聚在一起说这是一个大问题，每个人都应该处理它，我们应该共同努力改变它。
I don't know, it's like I've gotten so used to deciding everything. Like I've had moments where I'll think about something outside of school, and think, oh, I should vote on it. And then I can't vote on it. I feel bad that a lot of people don't have the power in their environment like we do. Because we get to change anything about the school that we want to.
我不知道，就像我已经习惯了决定一切。就像我有过在校外思考某件事，然后想，哦，我应该投它一票的时刻。然后我无法投它一票。我觉得很多人在他们的环境中没有像我们这样的权力，这很糟糕。因为我们能改变关于学校的任何我们想要改变的事情。
When she came into the school five years ago, Malia was scared to say what was on her mind. Over the years, she's learned to speak up, and she's seen that lead to change. She admits the meetings can be boring and frustrating, but she takes the authority she's given by the school very seriously. All the kids do. Malia feels bad for adults, she said, because they can't just call a meeting and take a vote at their jobs, or wherever, to fix something that bothers them. I get that. Once you're grown up, democracy is not so pure.
当她五年前进入学校时，马莉亚不敢说出自己的想法。多年来，她学会了发言，并看到这带来了改变。她承认会议可能会很无聊和令人沮丧，但她非常认真地对待学校赋予她的权威。所有的孩子都这样。马莉亚为成年人感到难过，她说，因为他们不能仅仅在工作中，或者任何地方，为了解决困扰他们的事情而召集会议并进行投票。我明白了。一旦你长大了，民主就不那么纯粹了。
Jyllian Gunther. She's a filmmaker currently finishing a film about an new public high school in Brooklyn.
吉莲·冈瑟。她是一位电影制作人，目前正在完成一部关于布鲁克林一所新公立高中的电影。
[MUSIC - "IF THE KIDS ARE UNITED (THEY'LL NEVER BE DIVIDED)" BY SHAM-69]
[音乐 - 萨姆-69乐队的“如果孩子们团结（他们永远不会被分开）”]
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Nancy Updike. Senior producer for our show is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Production help from Shawn Wen and Eric Mennel.
我们今天的节目由莎拉·柯尼格制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、南希·厄普代克。我们节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。制作帮助来自肖恩·温和埃里克·门内尔。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
That amazing film, Please Vote For Me, about the third grade election, originally aired on Independent Lens on PBS. You can buy a copy online. We link from our website, thisamericanlife.org. We say goodbye this week to our intern, Shawn Wen, who's been great to work with, and who we wish the very best.
那部关于三年级选举的精彩电影《请为我投票》，最初是在PBS的《独立镜头》上播出的。你可以在线购买副本。我们在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上链接了它。我们本周要告别我们的实习生肖恩·温，和她一起工作非常棒，我们祝愿她一切顺利。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's been puzzling over the every-changing FCC rules, until he finally arrivede at this:
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他一直在为FCC不断变化的规则感到困惑，直到他终于得出了这一点：
Whoever the hell made up these curse words was really wrong.
无论谁发明了这些诅咒词，真的错了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。